[Musique]
une chanson tout indiquée après une
tragédie sans nom
[Musique]
une messe pour rendre hommage aux deux
enfants dont les vits ont été fauchées
il y a deux jours quand on regarde tous
ces toutous sont devant nous même les
toutous ont les yeux tresses le curry
Michel Bouchard a tenté de trouver les
mots pour apaiser et conforter malgré
l'incompréhensible la prière est là pour
nous aider à exporter sa remplace pas
les personnes disparues évidemment mais
avec le temps ça nous aide à penser à
travers et ces enfants-là des deux que
j'ai baptisé et donc je vais faire des
funérailles dans une semaine ce serait
celle du petit garçon Jacob Gauthier 4
ans son oncle André Riom a assisté à la
cérémonie
il y a quelques années
ça réveille ça réveille des sentiments
des sentiments douloureux même pour les
familles qui ne se connaissent pas j'ai
des enfants aussi elles ont 5 heures
c'était vraiment ça m'a touché beaucoup
devant l'impuissance les gens sentent le
besoin de se rallier derrière les
familles endeuillées pourquoi vous êtes
la force de passer à travers ça dans les
prochains jours les prochaines années
un élan de solidarité qui souffle sur
tout le Québec
à la garderie Les rikiki à
Trois-Rivières Maria lira belorin
accroché des doudous blancs sans guise
de drapeau blanc c'est ce que tous les
enfants utilisent à la garderie pour se
rassurer c'est leur sentiment de
sécurité un mouvement qui a fait des
petits d'un bout à l'autre du Québec au
Saguenay à Rimouski les éducatrices de
partout sont solidaires on a vraiment
souhaité appuyer les enfants les
familles qui ont vécu là un choc
exceptionnel la poussière n'est pas tout
à fait retombée mais la psychosocial
sera là pour rester assure les autorités
de santé à Laval alors que Sainte-Rose
ne fait qu'entamer son deuil ici Jacques
Audric Charbonneau Radio-Canada
là-bas